what about all these threats and danger
is it all from the US government or
other other entities or yeah man it's
it's really Dynamic so I'm going to try
to answer you like really directly um I
have to be I have to dance a little bit
but I'm going try to answer you really
directly there are many interests to and
I'm going to say this real clear shape
the emerging UAP narrative in quote
imagine that in a document from an
intelligence agency okay so what that
means is the the threats are like well
is my family going to be okay am I going
to lose a clearance right so for people
that are in the military you know will I
be defamed to the point like they tried
with David grush where no one's going to
hire the guy I always buy someone
representing the US government I mean
it's not like Elizabeth Warren's
assistant is coming after you right so
no yeah because who are the holders of
the secrets remember a lot of this
technology is said to have been put into
Private Industry so think like you think
about like big tobacco I mean they did
some diabolical [__] to people that were
blowing the whistle this is more
important and bigger than that so when
you move something in Private Industry
they have their own kind of Rules of
Engagement so is it always the US
government no most everybody in the US
government wants to know what's going on
but when you move things into Private
Industry and you give them power they
can operate by different rules now of
course they are defense contractors
right but that that those threats that
pressure that shut up silence don't talk
about this we're going to Mock You it
comes
from mechanisms with within Private
Industry it feeds down to social media
and then people are co-opted by our
intelligence agencies do you remember
project Mockingbird that came out uh
back in the day in Congress sounds
Vaguely Familiar it's where they opt
journalists where they grab them they
pay them or they threaten them the CIA
was doing this and this is like not a
conspiracy this is like like a real
thing that happened and it came out back
in the day with a a very important event
that occurred in Congress which we'll
talk about later but that is real and
that happens now personally I have
something wrong with my brain I am just
I dropped my last [__] a long time ago I
am not going to endanger National
Security but I am definitely going to
pursue this and tell the truth so so I'm
not too worried about it but I've seen
other people harmed what they did to
David Gru
was [__] horrible but the thing is he
was ready for it first conversation I
had with him is what dirt are they going
to pull up and how are they going to
hurt you because they're gonna if what
you're saying is true they're gonna he
came to me and George first now for
anybody who's not clear David grush is
the guy who we all saw testify in front
of Congress yeah saying that they they
have uh nonhuman bio biologics you got
it
meaning meaning that he testified under
oath that the US government is in
possession of actual
Anonymous aircraft plus non-human
biologic meaning like uh effectively Ali
alien Pilots of of uh these n aircraft
are they alive or dead still so they
would be dead F what right first of all
check this out first of all the reason
we use non-human intelligence when we're
talking about this is because we don't
want to make presumptions is it ET extr
terrestrial is it extra dimensional a or
it could just be from from where just a
hidden intelligence that's called
ultraterrestrial right like uh some
people that have been here longer than
us are they piloting the craft sometimes
they are are the craft run with an
artificial intelligence so it's a drone
that's a great word for a drone sure all
and yes and of the above
yes and Time Travelers extemporal so so
we could go through there's like four or
five big theories on where these things
come from but why you say non-human
intelligence is because you're just
trying to like leave the door open and
not make an assumption like an idiot
right like you know where it comes from
right now there are people that claim
that they know and all that stuff and I
will tell you this the craft that we
have obtained our government
specifically the DIA the head of the DIA
program defense intelligence so the DIA
is intelligence agency it's called the
defense intelligence agency it was
admitted that they had a UFO program you
heard about it in the New York Times
They called it a different name but you
heard about it that was the 2017 article
yeah a tip they called it right but the
the main program the mother program was
called AAP I had the head of the DIA UFO
program come on my podcast with George
nap called weaponized and he admitted
that they had a craft that they obtained
a craft just one he admitted to one and
they breached the whole of it it wasn't
made by us wasn't China wasn't Russia so
they call it non-human intelligence
right because we're not exactly sure or
I'm not exactly sure where the the
pilots or The Operators of The Craft are
from but that is fact he got authorized
to say it through a doser request which
just means he asked the government hey
what can I talk about you know I'm
writing books so but he admitted it on
the show and that's just one where he
found it well he didn't find it he was
the the head of the the program studying
it so you got people studying the craft
but let me get back to the point which
is that where are they
from what is their
intent those are the big questions but
we can't even get there unless we come
to consensus reality that we got these
craft and I'll tell you something about
the craft and why I think they're not
from here from Earth is because the
structure the way they're built they are
capable of Beyond Interstellar travel so
anybody that's ever worked in these
programs who I do continue to talk to
who are currently in them and people
that have been in them say the craft
themselves are capable of you say faster
than speed faster than light but that's
not the case they're gravitationally
propelled so they warp space time but
they're capable structurally of moving
you know within solar systems and Beyond
yeah so that would be going to other
sons and so why would you make a Ferrari
if you're just you know at home in your
driveway never going to leave the gate
right so that tells me something that
tells me they're probably from another
star system but there might be multiple
things going on there could be some that
are like that there could be some that
are interdimensional people say I don't
know what that means but I kind of
understand yeah that seems like it makes
sense what what's the leading theory on
where aliens are from well the the
leading theory from the people that
actually work in these UFO reverse
engineering exploitation programs for
derivative Technologies unpack that [__]
right what they say is that they get
conflicting ideas meaning there might be
more than like one group of other people
from other places coming here so it
could be all of the above in the kitchen
SN I don't know that's what this is all
about if this is real let's start
talking about
it the the idea that I got as far as why
the government takes this so seriously
and why why the government's been so
secretive
I kind of just heard the message that
the government was embarrassed to admit
that what they know about this
anomalist uh you know craft all this UFO
stuff is that it is a technology so far
Advanced beyond anything that we as
human humans are capable of it defies
everything scientifically that that that
we even understand and as such if this
phenomena was to turn hostile the the
the government is well aware that it
cannot defend its own Skies it cannot
defend its own people that like if if
this
anomalous phenomena turns
you can even say aliens whatever
somewhere some else yeah they can just
they can kick our ass there's nothing we
can do about we're at their Mercy for
sure and the government was embarrassed
to admit that and and that's why they
wanted to keep a lid on it all that
that's what I it would cause Mass
hysteria too if they announc hey there's
aliens and they could take us out at any
moment do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude